for the tampa bay rays it will be lefty
shane mcclanahan making his 15th start
of the season picked up his fourth win
his last timeout against the baltimore
orioles we talked about that ball game
in the open five innings one earned run
seven strikeouts most swings and misses
22 that he has had in any start this
season you hope to continue that ball
rolling down the hill here tonight
dj lemayo
and 265 seven homers and 37 rbis head
sharply past diaz and that'll go down
the left field line it goes all the way
to the wall lamellae is motoring to
second he makes a turn he'll stop right
there a lead-off double for d.j lemayo
it's his 15th double of the year he has
a streak of now 36 games reaching base
it's hard not to misjudge when he's uh
out and he's been out for nine games
yankees
survived to the tune of five and four
but what could have been losing some
tough games cut on hit on the ground
base it left field lemayo had a late
start the ball was in the left side so
he holds the third so judge singles hard
to left in the shortstop hole yankees
have the bases loaded one out and here
is glebe torres let's see if the yankees
take advantage of this first inning
granted a short double play ball and the
yankees will not score in the end a
six-fourth double-a yankee specialty and
they don't score remember that later in
the game well you're asking monty to
back it up he had a phenomenal start
against the red sox was all set up for
the win before the bullpen imploded five
and two third shutout innings
just hope that he can do the same and i
always love to watch him find his
curveball early i know pitchers pitch
around their fastball but his curveball
is so important red sox were one for
nine with five k's against his curveball
and high five his fifth start against
the raise he's been very good one on and
one out and here is our first look at
nelson cruz in the tampa bay uniform
goes slow to third
got him
and margot is out as gary sanchez
through a laser to third watch this
throw
my goodness he laid it
right in front of the bag on the money
or shell let's just catch
and just leave it there the tag right
down to the oven mitt now let's see if
the yankees now lamar is two and two
let's even get the run in and a captain
he went up
and with with a slider that stayed up
there here's greg allen with the corners
up brayton ball strike three the yankees
don't score again no runs one hit and
one left here is nelson cruz this is a
great opportunity for the race two one
and one out hit on the ground ashore
double play ball feed second one on to
first it's a double play
now the yankees get out of that
montgomery has thrown 62 pitches in
three innings so he's had a battle here
is lamar with runners at first and
second and two of lamar struck out his
first time he's a right-hand hitter grad
at the second
lao throws to first end time and that
will end the inning no runs one hit and
two left of admit in scoring position in
each of the first three innings we are
scorers and he'll deal one two to zunino
strike three
and both pitchers are just living on a
razor's edge and yet we're still
scoreless now let's see if the yankees
can move that runner they have a runner
at second and no one out and they have
all their big hitters coming up hit on
the ground to the right side beautiful
job by lemayo
coming around third is alan the throw
home is not in time it's a base hit and
an rbi for dj lemayo
and the yankees take a one-nothing lead
and dj
tried to do that
he took a pitch and went with it hitting
it to the right side past the uh the
glove of brandon lau one nothing yanks
and one of the things you've got to love
is the is the speed of greg allen that's
the third walk given up by monty since
2020 crews hitting 392 against
left-handed pitching here in boone
staying with montgomery here dragon ball
cutout of miss that's terrific work by
montgomery he pitched five strong
innings tonight two straight singles to
right first and third know it out and
here is geo shell
that one is lined into left center field
it's a base hit let's see if it splits
the outfielders it's cut off in the gap
by kier meyer and they are going to wave
homo door here's the throw here's the
play he's in there urchella with a two
run double in the yankees lead three
nothing odor came all the way home on a
double in the left center field gap by
arshella big hit and the yankees take a
three-nothing lead
and ruby odor who does everything with a
lot of flare just slid in both hands to
home plate
ahead of the throw great great
they're going down the gauntlet ruby
leads the gauntlet this time
well there's a red light there by phil
nevin and odor ran right through it well
here's lemayo who is two for three
swinging a little looper and a shallow
right loud going out margot coming in or
goes slides and makes the catch to take
away a basement from the mayhew and keep
the yankees from adding on nice play by
man walmart going right
that little blooper was
gonna be trouble but he made the catch
and so with two outs and a runner at
first here's brandon lau three nothing
new york is the rays just can't get the
big hit there's a swing and a fly ball
left field and deep lamar going back to
the wall it's gone
brandon lau goes out
he gets him in and it's a 3-2 game 22nd
homerun of the season for brandon knocks
in g-man choi
for his 50th and 51st runs batted in
and the razor cut the deficit to one and
let's face it the final two months is so
important and they have
you know what looks like a nice lead
three-nothing montgomery was great bang
it's 3-2 here's ryan lamarr he's a
right-hand hitter i want to hit to right
field and deep going back more go on the
track at the wall see ya a home run the
other way for lamar and the yankees lead
four to two flying ryan coming home
that's lamar's second home run he got a
little pop made it the opposite way to
right field and the yankees take a 4-2
lead gray's down a pair of runs in the
bottom of the eighth the as it's second
and now rosarina swinger line drives
down the rainfield line fair or foul
it's a fair ball takes a bounce and goes
out of play diaz will score a rosarito
to center by the automatic double it's a
one-run new york lead for three yankees
so here is chapman three hits and an
earned run allowed in the last six
innings he's pitched swing and a miss
blew it right by him three straight fast
balls one away so one away and that'll
bring up manuel morgo and that one is
punched out into center field and it's
caught by a diving allen for the second
out
beautiful play by greg allen good jump
and he hauls it in for out number two
chapman love to see it now if you're the
race your
chances rest in a 20 year old
[Music]
but here's nelson cruz
with one swing he can win the game for
tampa yankees have a 4-3 lead russell
cruz homer against chapman earlier this
year
walked him off because he got another
one in him now here's the payout pitch
swinging and miss got him
chapman saves it and the yankees win 4-3
and we've said this before
if there's going to be a dvd of this
season the title is going to be it don't
come easy